good morning and welcome to the Nobel
Week dialog my name is Adam Smith and
it's my very great pleasure to be your
guide to today's meeting on the future
of truth now one of the things we'll be
discussing today is the question of what
we can rely on and no doubt we'll find
answers to that question but
unfortunately one thing we know we can't
rely on our flight schedules and I'm
very sorry to say that our first speaker
Lars hakin Steen executive director of
the Nobel Foundation has been detained
in Stockholm this morning by a canceled
flight so in his place it gives me great
pleasure to welcome Lara sparklin deputy
CEO of noble media to read his welcome
address Lara
[Applause]
your excellencies dear Nobel laureates
ladies and gentlemen dear friends good
morning you're more than welcome to
Nobel week dialogue 2017 when the Nobel
dialogue was held in Gothenburg in 1915
two years ago I'd opened the event
talking about the dark autumn that was
behind us with the profound refugee
crisis in Europe regrettably the world
has hardly become better or more
peaceful since then we are now living
with an acute threat of nuclear war in
Korea and increased tensions in the
Middle East
human rights are being violated in
Myanmar Nobel laureate Lucia Bohr was
not let out of prison in China until he
was dying our own societies the Western
democracies also have problems the
foundations on which we build stable
democracies and secured a rapid
improvement in living standards are
shaking exchanges between countries
migration and trade are being fought by
populist science indeed even knowledge
in pure facts are being questioned the
climate change issue is just another
example but a potentially fatal one
hidden behind these developments are
complicated processes although many
people in previously poor countries have
seen their lives improve social and
economic tensions in much of the worst
Western world have increased this trend
has been reinforced by problems in the
educational systems of many countries
not contributing to more
her life chances as they did before
digital progress with all the
opportunities it brings also seems to
divide us pushing us into our own
bubbles Alfred Nobel stood for progress
in the opposite direction
he believed in knowledge and science and
in the opportunities to use them to
build stronger societies both more
democratic and with better living
conditions he himself was deeply
interested in the humanities literature
and philosophy he also wanted to help
secure peace it was with these ideals
these thoughts in the back of his mind
that he formulated his will and
instituted the prices that bear his name
this is the spirit in which we organized
the Nobel Week dialogue we choose a
topic this year the future of truth what
could be more important today together
with some of the world's sharpest minds
including a number of new bell laureates
we will discuss what the truth really is
and what is required for the truth truth
to become known and to become respected
Trust is a key issue and there were
specially privileged the Nobel Prize
enjoys a very high level of trust this
gives us a special responsibility our
task is to act in the spirit of Alfred
Nobel for the greatest benefit to
humanity this is more important today
than ever before in my lifetime with the
Nobel Prize we highlight the fields that
Nobel was engaged in the contributions
that are being rewarded and the people
who have received the prize they become
important role models in addition over
the past 20 years we have organized
broad public activities aimed at
informing and inspiring people this
includes
presents during the week when this
year's Nobel laureates were announced
we reached 13 million people a day
through our digital channels mostly
young and many women as many women as
men we also run museums and within a few
years we hope to create a new noble
Centre in Stockholm it will serve as the
base for both our large-scale
local activities and our broader digital
and international work we could not do
this without support from many
directions we use Alfred Nobel's money
for the purposes that he explicitly
stated in his will
for the rest of our activities we need
help from others our first and strongest
supporter of the Nobel Week dialogue has
been called Bennett but he's far from
alone the city of Gothenburg and the
West Island region have supported us
since we started in 2012 and is
therefore especially heartening for us
to be here in Gothenburg again this year
also important our Ericsson and this
dinner ulsan foundation thank you all
for your involvement let me close by
thanking all of you who are here today
and who gave have got up early on a
Saturday morning to be with us of course
I would also like to thank all of you
who in many cases have travelled long
distance in order to join us on stage or
behind the scenes you are the ones who
made this event possible
I'm looking forward to today's exciting
discussions as usual I'm convinced that
Alfred Nobel would have done so too if
he had been among us once again a warm
welcome to this year's Nobel week that I
look in Gothenburg and before I leave
the stage please allow me to go back to
my real self and say warm welcome to you
all and thank you
[Applause]